je suis en master 1 de psychologie et ce
matin le professeur qui nous fait court
est un docteur en psychologie d'une
soixantaine d'années qui est un homme
absolument remarquable qui a une
capacité absolument extraordinaire à
nous transmettre les connaissances à
nous transmettre sa connaissance et le
cours de ce matin est dédié à quelque
chose de très particulier
il évoque les différentes formes de
thérapies existantes et à un moment
donné du cours d'une manière très
tonitruante il nous dit pour moi il n'y
a que deux thérapies qui sont efficaces
la thérapie cognitivo comportementale et
l'hypnose intéressant le garde en
mémoire replacer cela dans le contexte
c'était il ya quinze ans il ya 15 ans
trouvé un thérapeute qui pratiquer
l'hypnose était un peu compliqué mais ma
curiosité naturelle me pousse à chercher
trouver et prendre un rendez vous je
ressors du rendez vous et je me dis mais
comment ça marche
mon côté cartésien a besoin de
comprendre
j'étais là sans être là tout en étant là
perturbant quelques années plus tard
suite à un accident de la route je me
tourne naturellement vers l'hypnose pour
utiliser cette technique pour accélérer
la rééducation
et puis pour digérer émotionnellement
l'événement et j'en tire très vite la
conclusion qu'il me semble que cet outil
est absolument indissociable de la
pratique professionnelle que j'ai envie
d'avoir dans mon quotidien je suis
psychologue et neuro psychologue
spécialisé en gériatrie
j'accompagne tous les jours les
personnes âgées qui présente ou non des
troubles cognitifs et j'ai la chance de
former les professionnels de santé à des
techniques de prise en soin j'ai aussi
la chance d'avoir un libéral de
thérapeutes qui me permet de pouvoir
rencontrer des adultes aux jeunes alors
dans mon langage à moi qui suis
spécialisé en gériatrie un adulte jeune
est quelqu'un qui a moins de 70 ans j'ai
la croyance que la vie pose sur notre
chemin
ce dont nous avons besoin pour pouvoir
évoluer à nous de savoir l'observer et à
nous de savoir nous en saisir alors le
jour où j'ai la possibilité de pouvoir
faire la formation en hypnose et de
découvrir cet outil incroyable
je saisis l'opportunité alors même qu'on
est encore à une époque où l'hypnose est
très empreinte de tout ce qui relève du
spectacle voire de la manipulation
mentale et pourtant je sais que c'est
bien autre chose
pour l'avoir testé moi-même pendant que
je suis en formation
j'écoute j'entends j'apprends j'écoute
les formateurs nous expliquer comment on
met en état de transe quelqu'un et je
souris
je souris parce que je fais des ponts je
me dis c'est quand même très étonnant en
hypnose il appelle ça comme ça en
psychologie l'appel autrement chacun son
langage et en même temps les mêmes idées
communes
et l'hypnose
qu'est ce que c'est depuis quelques
années ito s'installe progressivement
dans les blocs opératoires ce qui lui
permet de timidement mais tranquillement
sortir de toute cette représentation
pour le rendre finalement à son statut
d'origine à savoir quelque chose de
naturel mais qu'est ce que c'est
l'hypnose est ce que l'on appelle
communément un état modifié de la
conscience les neurosciences ont mis en
évidence grâce aux techniques d'imagerie
cérébrale que pour que cet état si
particulier secret il faut que deux
zones de notre cerveau s'associent
ensemble pour générer à la fois des
images mentales et en même temps une
représentation et une interprétation de
l'environnement immédiat
j'ai une bonne nouvelle
nous venons tous au monde fabriqué est
équipée en série de ces deux zones là et
le quotidien nous le prouve
si ici maintenant
dans cette salle je vous propose de vous
remémorer un moment très agréable de vos
dernières vacances de vous le remémorer
complètement dans les moindres détails
à la fois les couleurs à la fois
laissons la sensation de votre corps
dans cet endroit là la température la
luminosité les odeurs
progressivement vous allez oublier le
siège sur lequel vous êtes installés et
peut-être même votre voisin imaginez
imaginer que les états de conscience
sont comme les octaves du clavier d'un
piano
vous êtes assis devant il y à la fois
les touches blanches et les touches
noires et si sur ce piano vous avez pris
l'habitude la manie de toujours utiliser
les mêmes touches alors vous produisez
toujours la même musique
les mêmes comportements les mêmes
croyances les mêmes rituels et donc les
mêmes résultats
un jour vous vous apercevez que vous
pouvez utiliser d'autres touches créant
alors d'autres mélodies d'autres
harmonique d'autres comportements et
donc d'autres possibilités l'hypnose
l'hypnose nous permet de pouvoir
franchir un cap
les files aux nous permet de pouvoir
découvrir autre chose
l'hypnose nous permet de pouvoir sortir
du mode automatique dans lequel nous
nous sommes installés tout simplement de
par notre histoire de vie de par nos
apprentissages mode automatique qui est
nécessaire à notre survie mode
automatique qui nous permet de pouvoir
nous protège et qui nous permet de
pouvoir aller plus vite que notre
compréhension et que notre réflexion
un mode automatique rapide certes mais
qui coupent et qui court circuite
l'accès à la conscience
alors lorsque ce mode automatique qui
nous permet de pouvoir nous protège et
devient inconfortable
les gens viennent découvrir l'état
d'hypnose
tout simplement parce que ce mode
automatique ne sait pas se remettre en
question tout seul tout simplement parce
que ce mode automatique ne s'est pas
renégocié tout seul alors en venant
explorer l'état d'hypnose les personnes
ont accès à cette partie moins
consciente de même qui leur permet de
pouvoir créer les réajustements qui leur
sont nécessaires dans leur quotidien et
le thérapeute est là pour ça le
thérapeute est là pour créer le cadre
qui va permettre à la personne ne
pouvoir aller à la rencontre de cette
partie d'elle même permettez moi de vous
emmener quelques instants en séance à la
rencontre de christelle christelle
essaye d'avoir un enfant depuis dix ans
avec son mari et pourtant rien ils n'y
arrivent pas ils sont suivis
médicalement il décide d'arrêter le
suivi médical tout simplement parce que
les médecins leur explique que tout va
bien
rien ne fonctionne ni les stimulations
mais les fécondations in vitro
alors un jour christelle se dit et si
j'allais essayer de jouer une autre
mélodie sur mon piano elle vient en
séance et la première séance
elle évoque son anamnèse l'anamnèse
c'est l'histoire que christelle se
raconte à la deuxième séance
christelle comment ce travail en hypnose
et elle fabrique à l'intérieur d'elle
une machine absolument incroyable fait
deux rouages de pont de bacs remplis
d'eau qu'elle en robe dans un nuage dans
lequel elle met des couleurs et des
outils que elle pense nécessaire pour la
réussite de son objectif et tous les
soirs elle active sa machine à
l'intérieur d'elle même et surtout elle
le vit comme si c'était vrai pour elle
et elle leur sens comme si c'était vrai
pour elle à l'intérieur d'elle alors
bien sûr vous l'aurez deviné quelques
semaines plus tard une belle surprise
attention il ne s'agit pas d'installer
l'hypnose dans une pensée magique ni
même dans la croyance que ça fonctionne
comme ça tout le temps pour tout le
monde de cette manière là en aucun cas
il n'y a pas de bouton magique à
l'intérieur d'une personne sur lequel on
appuie et puis tout change tout se
transforme
par contre et ça c'est vraiment
important
nous avons tous cette ressource à
l'intérieur de nous et il y a la
possibilité de pouvoir l'activer
l'hypnose n'est qu'un outil seulement un
outil celui qui nous permette de pouvoir
retrouver le chemin vers cette partie
moins consciente de soi même et de
recréer un dialogue avec elle de
converser avec elle
l'hypnose n'en dors pas l'hypnose et
veille là où il y avait conditionnement
là où il y avait habitude apprentissage
l'hypnose recréer du choix l'hypnose
recréer de la liberté recrée du libre
arbitre
avant elle la méditation lui a ouvert la
voie
celle d'une manière de penser de l'être
humain qui dorénavant apprend à regarder
à l'intérieur de lui-même pour trouver
les solutions
juste là non plus seulement au niveau de
la tête mais au niveau du corps au
niveau du ressenti au niveau des
émotions juste là au niveau du coeur
alors si cette nouvelle attention que
l'on se porte à soi même nous permet de
nous mettre en état d'hypnose en état de
possibilités en état de nouvelles
compétences
qu'attendons nous qu'attendons nous pour
nous autoriser à explorer toute la gamme
de notre piano personnel de nos états de
conscience aux et il faut remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]